beckylyn Bailey what's your question for
someone else we've got to be quickly
it's a Kia would you keep the top rate
of tax that we had set out in our
manifesto with a 50 p tax rate because
you've been quite ambiguous about your
answer yes yes good okay listen Andy I
feel a bit ashamed about this question
after hearing that Paxman s compression
okay I was going to say to the other two
candidates can we go for a drink after
this contest yes if so we're gonna tour
Camden and what are you drinking go on
then it's a right answer to this Kia
wicked
kiss and what you're doing can kiss
Darla I'll have a pint of bitter okay
drink gin what's your question to you
and other kinds of it my question is
this if I'm if I succeed in this will
you work with me to unite our party so
that we can fight as a collective force
going forward to the next general
election together yes absolutely and
more than that Alan I'll tell you the
truth like Becky says behind closed
doors and I know she will too and
together we'll get it right okay
thank you very much that's almost it
from Jews group of here before we go
very quick straw poll from our audience
he thought kiss Dharma wandered away
hands up
Lisa Nandi Rebecca LAN Bailey very
unrepresentative straw poll of course
but there you go thank you very much for
being such a lively audience